and as we've been hearing May the 9th is
Victory Day in Russia it marks the
Soviet Union's role in defeating Nazi
Germany in the second world war
President Putin will lead the
celebrations which include a military
parade in Moscow now you're seeing
images of today's preparations Putin
will be looking to use the Pomp and
pageantry of the day to put a positive
spin on his war in Ukraine despite the
Russian military's sluggish campaign
there
now the occasion is also usually
celebrated by ethnic Russians in Latvia
which was occupied by the Soviet Union
for five decades but authorities have
banned celebrations this year in the
wake of Russia's war on Ukraine DW
correspondent Yuri rashetto went to
Latvia's city of dalgov peers here many
residents speak Russian Norwalk even
Russian citizens and this conflict has
left them questioning their own identity
there are few cities in the former
Soviet block which carry as many traces
over the Soviet past as dalgaf bills in
Latvia with more than 90 000 inhabitants
Latvia's second largest city has been
considered a Russian stronghold until
today every fourth person living in
Latvia is Russian this is the only city
where russian-speaking people are even
in the majority
most Russians came to dog of bills
during the Soviet era of the World War
II many residents here continue to feel
culturally drawn to Russia
some criticize the Latvian government
because it requires them to speak
Latvian the official language even
though many Russians can't speak it
language needs a linguistic environment
to live in
a person must be able to speak if he
can't it creates problems we want to
Latvia for everyone so that life remains
calm here
The Divide here between Russians and
latvians is evident every year on May
9th Victory Day of a Nazi Germany
but while Russians celebrate the Day for
many latvians World War II also
represents the beginning of Soviet
occupation
this year authorities finally decided to
cancel events because of Russia's war of
aggression in Ukraine a move some
criticize
surely this celebration isn't meant to
humiliate the Latvian Nation but we
Russians learn to celebrate this in
childhood we have it in our blood it
shouldn't be taken away
to be right recently in the capital Riga
hundreds of people from Latvia's
russian-speaking Community protested
against the Russian invasion and held a
rally in solidarity with Ukraine
[Music]
in the center of the Latin Capital
Russian speakers living here wanted to
show that they do not support the
policies of Vladimir Putin
[Music]
a deal to
us
but not everyone thinks so notes Russian
language journalist Ina plavoca a big
part of Russia's belief the Russian
propaganda and stand behind Putin she
says
our society is divided right now I can
feel that our communities are not United
and that scares me
this is a big problem for the security
of our country
blavoca says the linguistic divisions in
Latvia further separate people
and she believes the responsibility lies
with Russians who won't integrate
but she suspects Russia's war and
Ukraine could now change that
yeah
I suddenly felt very clearly that I am a
part of this country
it's a difficult admission but I don't
want to be part of Russia anymore even
though it's the country whose language I
speak music
in any case the Eternal Flame at the
Soviet Memorial in dog of bills will
burn on Victory Day
even without the official celebrations
let's speak now with Constantine Eggert
he's a DW correspondent and Russia
expert Constantine High this parade has
been rehearsed for days now what will
the 9th of May be this year because
after all Russia hasn't had this Triumph
in Ukraine that it really hoped for
yes everyone is speculating about it and
um visually there's going to be a an
interesting element to this uh parade uh
in a fly past which which has become a
pretty standard staple of this uh event
uh every year
um there's going to be a participation
by illusion80 the command and control
presidential uh flying uh sort of
headquarters
um that are supposed to be used also in
case of nuclear war uh so this huge
playing is going to be for the first
time flying for everyone to see uh along
the Red Square uh during the parade and
I think this is
um quite significant and I would say
ominous because uh it is very likely
that in his speech Putin will probably
mention some kind of Doomsday scenario
um he will essentially threaten Uh
unleashing Russian nuclear weapons in
case the world and Ukraine don't bend
their need to Moscow and I think that
this particular sort of element of the
parade participation by the presidential
kind of flying fortress HQ uh is
um is a signal
now huge preparations and and ominous
ones as you say you've just been
speaking a little bit about what we can
hear from Vladimir Putin can can you
elaborate a little bit more
well I suppose there were a lot of
speculations about what exactly Putin is
going to say and
I may be wrong of course but I think
that because of a lack of visible
clear victory in Ukraine put will have
to go around it and it's either
promising uh the uh Russian occupied
territories like the Donetsk and lugan's
regions or the Herzog region which was
mentioned in the previous report uh to
be accepted into Russia but I think uh
with no preparation or no visible
preparations for a referendum that's
probably a bit risky uh for him or he
will have to say uh that uh Russia's
stronger than ever and if anyone tries
to interfere we're going to strike you
with nuclear weapons and they think that
this is a bit more probable uh although
it's quite disturbing
Constantine let's talk a little bit
about Russians themselves because given
these vast International economic
sanctions and the fact that we don't
really know of course when this war is
going to end how is the Russian
government preparing them for the
impacts on their living standards and
possibly other sacrifices that they'll
have to make
well the preparation is usual for the
Putin's regime it's Relentless 24 7
propaganda first and foremost of all uh
secondly some money handouts to some uh
I would say strategic uh maybe elements
of the economy but that that is not huge
uh and I also think that uh there's a
very active work by the government on
trying to bypass and bend the sanctions
and uh um it's an interesting there's an
interesting detail to that
um there's a former minister of the
economy uh in Russia who was jailed for
corruption uh he's been urgently set
free from jail and he's a very very good
Economist his name is Alexei ulukaya so
he's been urgently set free on parole uh
from prison uh and it seems that he's
been going to be given a government post
uh to work on let's say creative but
creatively bypassing sanctions so I
think Putin will not stop because of
economic sanctions he will try to bypass
them he will try to use his ties to I
don't know India China to get more
economic aid uh but I think the essence
of it is that sanctions at least for now
will not stop this War uh they as we
know sanctions uh usually show their
effects over time half a year yeah
probably more and this is a huge time
when we talk about the conflict of the
Russian assault on Ukraine Constantine
Eggert there our DW correspondent thank
you
like